روسيا مساعده للعوده لاتفاق الحبوب في حال
تلبيه شروطها الاعلان على لسان فلاديمير
بوتين
ندرس امكانيه العوده الى الاتفاق ولكن
بشرط ان تؤخذ كل مبادئ مشاركه روسيا في
هذا الاتفاق في الاعتبار وتنفذ بالكامل
ومن دون استثناء
تصريح الرئيس الروسي ياتي غدا قصف منشات
تخزين الحبوب على البحر الاسود وقد حملت
كياف موسكو مسؤوليه ازمه غذائيه
استهدفت الصواريخ الروسيه الليله الماضيه
البنيه التحتيه للموانئ الاوكرانيه
المستخدمه في تصدير المنتجات الزراعيه ان
هذه الهجمات من قبل الارهابيين الروس ليست
فقط ضد بلدنا ولكن ايضا ضد الاستقرار
العالمي
برلين وباريس نددت بدورهما باستهداف مخازن
الحبوب
لقنبله من قنابل بوتين تصيب ايضا افقر
الاشخاص في العالم
الخارجيه الفرنسيه صنفت هذه الغارات جرائم
حرب واتهمت روسيا بتهديد الامن الغذائي
العالمي تزامنا مع تطورات ازمه تصدير
الحبوب قال مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
الهجوم المضاد الذي تقوم به كياف طويل
ومعقد واكد ان بلاده تحتاج الى دبابات
غربيه جديده والى طائرات اف 16 لصب القوات
الروسيه